I was waiting for a banker to drop off
some cash to me by only the only way I
could you can function in Afghanistan is
you have to have cash because there is
no banking system there is no credit
card there is no check so I had a big
coat like lots of pockets in that coat
and every day between a hundred two
hundred thousand I would stuff in my
pockets and just pay people cash as they
were corruption is beyond words it's the
second most corrupt country in the world
and I think it's well on its way to be
number one after Somalia but so when you
see people there is no laws rules of
regulation there is you can go and say
well i just gave you fifty thousand he
could come and back and say no you
didn't you don't know what to do about
that it's not like the United States
well I'm going to call my lawyer you
just it's gone that money is gone so you
just you have to feel people and you
have to trust so I needed to make weekly
payments to to the staff and the workers
and crew and he told me that I stay
cannot leave the set because I was
shooting as if you could please bring me
$50,000 by 6pm at this location and he
said okay I'm coming with a black car
and I'd never met him before he came I
saw a black car parked in front I saw
him and he says get in the car I got in
the car we set up we go around the
corner and i'll pay you the money
because i had to give 70,000 i had
20,000 and he needed 50,000 and all a
sudden to keep going and going and i am
getting almost out of the city
completely and i said where are we going
and he said well how much do you have
how much do I have I said where is my
money how much do you have and he said
what are you talking about I said aren't
you with the bank didn't you bring me
money black are coming in bringing me
the money he just laughed really like
this obnoxious laugh that just chills
you know and the bone and I looked at
him he said what do you want and he said
well I could hold you and get some money
or I could kill you and get some money
or if you have some money you could give
it to me now depending how much you have
I said I have twenty thousand dollars it
was in my pocket I hand it to him I
showed it to him and I said you if you
take me nobody's going to give you money
because I've already written letters not
to release me from the Taliban if I got
caught so that's useless but you can
have this but you have to take me back
right now and mm-hmm excuse me that's
how I negotiated my deal with them the
next thing that happened was I think it
was for four days after that this guy
who was driving me at security company
there was we change security companies
quite often also because you know you
don't know who is involved with the
security company you know one of these
bodyguards which we had between 80 and
70 a day one of them could be you know
the one that has ready to kill you so I
sitting in my car and with one of these
bodyguards it's about three thirty in
the morning we're going to uh nuh set 5
o'clocks and about couple hours of
perigo a little bit north of kabul in
all of a sudden it's dark so i'm looking
for my telephone in my bag i'm searching
for dallas and I felt something soft
and I put the light of my phone on it
there is a hand a chopped-up hands
sitting right next to me every hair on
my body stood up I said oh my god i said
to driver I said stop the car I said
there was a hand and and the other seat
and he looks at me he goes oh I when I
was coming to pick you up there was a
suicide bombing the windows were open
probably some limb flew in so I said
would get it out of the car and he goes
no no I can't stop right now i gotta
take you there and then i'll bury it
somewhere i still think about that it
just
if you honestly you never think
something like this could ever happen
and then when it does happen and then
you have to live with it and it just to
see either this was planned to scare me
or if it was a fact the truth he was
telling me in either case it showed to
me how cold and callous people have
become how non-important death is and a
limb in the car is like not a big deal
just to him it was like yeah another one
you know another problem that we just
got to take care of and the numbness
that people have seen so much death and
destruction that it just was nothing I
don't know which one was worse finding
that or finding his reaction to it a lot
of full-on big stories like that happen